clark county school district also
working to manage the virus there have
been more than 350 positive cases
reported this month 43 this week
reporter kate houston live from a staff
covet testing site with what educators
are saying about protocols in the
classroom
yes well ruth five elementary school is
one of 10 testing sites that are open
today there's just a few cars here this
evening mandatory testing is one aspect
of the district safety protocols others
include social distancing mask wearing
and seating charts but whether or not
schools are following through with that
is mixed
i just feel like we could be taking
better precautions less than two weeks
into the school year and some teachers
say safety protocols are not being
followed the district has not been firm
on that where students are being allowed
to use the same supplies elementary
school teacher amy says a return to full
capacity has made social distancing a
challenge the recommendation
is that students sit three feet apart
however that is impossible
in small classrooms
with many children and
cafeterias in many schools ccsd says
staff members and students are required
to be six feet apart however the
distance between two students is six
feet when possible at least three feet
is recommended this is something like
we've not experienced in a very long
time kristin nigro has 26 students in
her kindergarten class at steve shore
elementary these red stars indicate
where students are supposed to be in
order to stay distanced it's extremely
difficult to social distance students
especially in our school our enrollment
numbers have been way above than what we
ever imagined them to be with that said
nigro says her school has done a great
job at handling the guidelines i use
like individual crayon boxes and when
we're doing and using like manipulatives
like i'm literally like soaking them and
washing them and lysoline them as
schools deal with staff shortages and
changing guidelines she's asking parents
to go over hygiene and mask wearing with
their kids and that way we can continue
being face to face because i don't want
to go back to distance learning and i
know your kiddos don't either
right now lamping elementary is the only
school to go from in person learning to
distance learning due to positive covet
19 cases and the school district says
that teachers educators staff can work
with their school administrators if they
think that safety protocols are not
being followed reporting live tonight
near washington and valley view kate
houston 8 news now it's a work in
progress thanks kate we asked you on
twitter do you think all ccsd students
should return to long distance learning
it was close 43 percent say yes 57
percent say no